welcome to this episode of click to
deploy
a series where we show you how easy it
is to deploy solutions from the google
cloud marketplace
in this episode i'll show you how to set
up an apache cassandra database
deployment
through google cloud marketplace
cassandra is an open source nosql
distributed database
that is typically used for training and
inference of deep
neural networks we'll start by searching
for cassandra in the gcp marketplace
for the purpose of this tutorial let's
choose the google click to deploy
a cassandra virtual machine we are sent
to this landing page which shows us some
very important information about
cassandra like
an overview of what cassandra is details
about the virtual machine and its
operating system
and most importantly the estimated
monthly cost of choosing this solution
let's click the launch button to start
this deployment now we get to choose
some important specifications for our
deployment
we'll start by naming our deployment for
this video we will name it cast-101
next we'll choose the zone for this
tutorial i'll keep the default zone
then we can decide on the cluster name
i'll choose the default test cluster
next we can determine the instance count
i'll keep the count as the default count
of three
next we will choose machine type for
this video i'll use
e2.hyman-4 which are cost optimized vms
finally you can also decide on other
specifications like network interface
firewall and enable stackdriver logging
and monitoring
now we've completed the specifications
we'll click the deploy button
great so now our cassandra vm is
deployed and now we see the deployment
manager
the deployment manager allows you to
create and manage cloud resources
here we see the deployed cassandra
instance which includes files that show
vm instance
disk and firewall information now we can
test out this cassandra instance by
running a couple commands
there you have it a cassandra instance
created with a click of a button
if you enjoyed this video please
subscribe and hit the like button
if you'd like to deploy your own
cassandra virtual machine on your own
make sure to click the link down below
thanks for watching
you